you've lived your whole life in a world
that is run by vampires and demons what
do you do when you realize the job to
save a daughter from certain death is it
worth it you're going to have to kill
every single creepy crawly nasty demon
monster that stands in your way and
maybe even humans I'm going to break
down the mistakes made what you should
do and how to beat the vampire demons in
Vampire Hunter D bloodlust this man is
going to regret being a vampire hunter
this guy is a damp here I have human
half vampire hybrid basically blade but
less cool he gets a warm welcome as he
meets with this guy and this other dude
who won't even look at him and they
offer him his next Bounty this guy's
Sister Charlotte has just been kidnapped
by a powerful vampire lord and
eyewitness accounts say that they know
who's responsible the man tells the Dom
here but we'll call him D that they want
him to bring her back alive before she
suffers a face that is in every single
vampire movie turning into a vampire
desperate the man tells Dee that he's
hired other vampire Hunters to do the
job as well whoever can bring Charlotte
back safe first will win the enormous
Bounty and D accepts the challenge later
he comes across another group of vampire
Hunters hired to find Charlotte but
their ride is broken not caring
whatsoever he rides off to find his
Target but happens to get followed by
one of the hunters this blonde girl the
next day he finally arrives at the
Noble's Hideout using his wits he
manages to get past the building's
security and places his hand on the wall
sensing that two people are inside and
he tries to track their movements just
as the sun goes down but he gets
interrupted by the blonde bounty hunter
from earlier because she shows up and
charges in guns blazing and totally
screws up his element of surprise the
vampire Lord's Carriage races off and
she fires her rocket launcher but the
vampire lord easily deflects it and
sends rapnol right back at her on the
run the vampire Lord's Carriage goes
through this tunnel just as D catches up
with them and the two get into a
showdown the vampire lord introduces
himself as Maier Inc a vampire known for
not harming humans the two fight on top
the carriage indeed lands a strike on
Lord my hair but out of nowhere Rd gets
distracted I see here's Charlotte call
out from below to my air out of concern
causing D to fall off the carriage and
watches Charlotte slips away okay I'm
going to flip my [__] and it's not for
what you think yes I can't be the only
one who was stunned to have the girl
we're trying to save call out to her
abductor but y'all are missing the point
why don't you take out the ride the
vampire lord clearly needs this Carriage
to be able to travel in daylight if he
didn't need it why would he just take
the girl and fly off to wherever he
needs to get to if I was Mr D I'm not
fighting to kill the vampire lord yet my
target is in him it's the girl I'm going
to do what I have to to get the vampire
guy away from the horses but once I can
get to them I'm gonna dice them up and
make him into a nice bowl of Versace The
Carriage will then crash and the Vampire
Lord will be stuck and I will have the
advantage could the girl die in the
crash sure but if she doesn't a few
broken bones means I could still bring
her home to Daddy and get my money Dee
thinks Something Fishy is going on with
Charlotte and my Heir but his wrinkle
face of a left hand thinks that she's
just under his hypnotic spell returning
to get his horse he sees the blonde lady
from earlier back badly injured he
decides to heal her up telling her that
her Bounty Hunter Squad will soon reach
her and he leaves later that night D
reaches a fort known to house terrifying
Monsters of all kinds known as the
barbaroids a group of mercenary
bodyguards Dee knows that these guys are
hiding Charlotte and my hair who is now
likely resting after his intense battle
and is vulnerable he demands that they
hand over the girl but the barbaroid
leader tells him that they've been
serving the vampire Lords for centuries
they refused to cooperate and simply
tell Dee that entering their Fort has
already sealed his fate knowing he's
outmatched D thinks fast and tells them
that ganging up on him is unfair and
will ruin the reputation of the guild
throughout the land instead He suggests
that they should match their best
fighters against him in a slightly more
fair battle to the death nearby blonde
hair girl squad has been tracking him
and they prepare to poach the Bounty for
themselves using their special weapon
this all-powerful psychic these three
bodyguards offered to fight D but that's
when everyone sees a strange bright
object approaching them and is coming
fast devastating beams of light shootout
from the psychic and he Slaughters
dozens of monsters using his powers okay
I'm now a bounty hunter who's going to
make a lot of money and I mean a lot if
I get my target back to her father alive
but I'm only human I'm not Japan's
version of Blade over here I have to be
more careful this isn't Twilight I can't
just follow my heart or in this case my
greed and rush in to take my prize
there's only a handful of us and we're
parked just outside of our Fortress
filled with monsters the guy they sent
in the psychic he's been sick since
birth and has been blessed with the
ability to project a psychic image of
himself that can interact with the real
world and affords him the ability to
fight and shoot blasts of mystical
energy from all parts of his psychic
form but every time he uses this power
he uses up his life force each time but
uh how about we go with my plan my plan
is to not send my Ace in the whole
ghosty guy over here until we really
need him since we would only have him
for a limited amount of time to begin
with what they should have done was just
to find a spot that they liked outside
of the Fortress near the exit road that
Lord Meyer's Carriage would have had to
go through in order to leave the
Fortress because it's clear that this
Fortress is not their final destination
which means that these guys could have
just waited right outside and hit them
when they were on their way out away
from the the majority of monsters this
move would have allowed blonde girls
team to hit the enemy Carriage hard and
fast and also taking into account
ghosties limited use of his powers while
still allowing them to successfully
rescue Charlotte or at least increase
their odds of pulling it off because
this group has the gear and the skills
of what they don't have is the manpower
to basically Blitzkrieg an entire
Fortress which is what they just did
this move is way too risky and is now
more than likely going to cost them the
psychic ghosty kills dozens of monsters
in seconds and its utter chaos the
barbaroid leader demands his best
hunters these three to escape with
Charlotte and my air immediately but
ghosty catches on and heads straight for
the carriage and runs into D the dampier
swiftly takes out ghosties psychic
projection causing its human host to go
into a seizure D charges after the evil
bounty hunters but then he runs into
this guy's magic trap imprisoning him
instantly meanwhile blonde girls team
continues to tell the character
throughout the night and one of the
idiots fires a rocket at the carriage in
response this green hair girl attacks
them and goes under their carriage and
absorbed through the floor of their
vehicle and sends terrifying spikes up
through the floor and nearly kills
everyone on on board and instantly
disables their vehicle blonde hair girls
gang then gets stranded in the desert
with nowhere to escape to green hair
girl's partner tells her that he's going
to stay behind and finish the job and
merges into the shadows and he prepares
to brutally Slaughter everyone here okay
this is horrifying because again we're
dealing with some insane mystical [__]
that makes absolutely no sense AKA
standard anime things but this is a case
where this group's bravery and
headstrong attitude could bleed into
arrogance if they're not careful yet
again they're up against a mystical
creature and have no way to escape due
to their broken down vehicle good job
guys if I'm one of the bounty hunters
and one of my guys told me that there's
another one out there we have to be
careful logically we have to assume that
a vampire would never employ other
vampires as bodyguards due to the very
nature of their species being unable to
tolerate the Sun during the day limiting
their travel by default this means that
it's almost guaranteed that these guys
are not up against more vampires but
something else entirely and that also
means the game has changed and for
whatever reason the thing Rob against
hasn't killed us yet which is actually a
good thing it makes me think that this
creature will try to take its time
toying with us before it brutally kills
us all choosing to horrify its victim
before killing them but it's because of
this we can use it to our advantage my
group is white out in the open and I can
see from all directions and the only
thing that's obstructing my view are
these massive oil rigs it's unlikely
that whatever is hunting us down is on
the rig farthest away from me meaning
it's probably hiding somewhere on the
rig closest to me the group should split
up and surround the oil rig from all
angles with blonde chick taking point
and sitting on top of my dystopian
Humvee thing she'll grab a hold of her
rocket launcher and aim it at the rig
headband guy will cover the left side of
it while redheaded guy take the other
side allowing us to cover almost every
side of the oil rig structure this will
allow us to close in on the monster and
will allow blonde girl to scare the
monster into revealing his location by
firing a rocket at the structure and by
doing this the creature will likely be
forced into switching positions on the
oil rig coming out of hiding the process
and this will allow the gang now
situated on all sides to better take out
this bastard once and for all using the
shadows as his ally the demon charges at
blonde hair girls group but suddenly he
senses that D has finally broken out of
his magic prison he panics knowing that
it won't be long before the world's
greatest Bounty Hunter reaches him picks
up the pace and moves in quickly for the
kill but headband guy sees this and
finally catches on to his moves and he
comes up with a plan on the Fly and his
team Sprints into action and manages to
finally kill him where he stands and the
team thinks that now they're their [__]
but their luck will run out sooner than
they think they work on fixing up their
broken down vehicle and decide to stop
at a nearby town to resupply but they
notice D in the distance he's finally
caught up with him exhausted these
wrinkle face of a left hand warns him
that unless he gets out of the sun soon
he'll soon die from Sun's sickness but D
doesn't listen and Powers through with
his mission afraid of D stealing their
Bounty blonde girl comes up with a plan
to slow him down and goes into the
town's bar and informs the sheriff that
a terrifying vampire Hunter is nearby
and that they must stop him before he
causes trouble meanwhile D finally
reaches the town stable and tries to buy
a new horse from this old fossil but he
gets interrupted by chisel chin Sheriff
who shows up and tells him that his kind
is forbidden in this town D tries to
reason with the sheriff but he doesn't
listen starting to think he's out of
options he gets ready to steal the horse
but finally his happy vampy luck finally
kicks in this old man then reveals a Big
Kahuna of a big fatty right in front of
the sheriff's face the old man tells Dee
that he owes him one that this old man
was actually one of the kids that he
saved decades ago and tells him to get
the hell out of Dodge with his new ride
later the noble vampire Maier tells the
evil bounty hunters to stop at this
River knowing that Charlotte soon won't
be able to see the sun ever again he
tells his bodyguards to back off and let
her enjoy her day in the sun one last
time getting some fresh air Charlotte
heads down to the far side of the lake
just as her eyes fill with dread seeing
Dee standing right across from her he
tells her to come with him but she
refuses Dee questions what's really
going on and Charlotte reveals the
horrifying truth she's in love with a
vampire lord Maier himself these Poker
Face is shocked but he tells her that
her family has paid him to bring her
back to them but she says that she'll
die before she leaves and that she wants
to become a vampire so he tells her that
if she does he's also been paid to kill
her the moment she turns into a
terrifying vampire because becoming one
of them means you're already dead so she
plays hard to get and then blonde girl
finally shows up trying to claim the
Bounty for herself she grabs Charlotte
and tries to leave with her threatening
Dee to back off but suddenly green hair
girl swipes blonde girl from above just
as bicep stud comes down to steal
Charlotte D wastes no time and uses his
super speed to catch up with him in the
forest but that's when he realizes that
something is not right he feels weak and
dizzy he collapses on the floor and his
wrinkle face left hand tells him what he
fears most he now has sun sickness okay
this is some old crap because our sexy
tall dark and handsome Edward Cullen
wannabe has now royally screwed up while
a damp here can Outlast regular vampires
in sunlight being able to withstand the
Sun for up to 6 months before catching
any sort of sun sickness our main hero
here he can stay out of the Sun for up
to five years before subcoming to the
sunlight sickness truly main hero stuff
but the terrifying thing about this
sickness is that it can happen without
warning even these left hand can't
detect when this will happen exactly for
what it does it means The Damp years are
basically unable to move or defend
themselves with the cure being that they
need to bury themselves in the ground in
order to rest leaving them vulnerable as
hell D things fast on how to not die and
runs into a patch of grass to hide
nearby wrinkleface tells them that if he
doesn't bury himself within the next few
minutes he'll be dead he summons up his
energy for one final move meanwhile
green-haired lady continues to search
the area for him but that's when he
surprises her and Strikes her down
chopping off her head barely conscious D
desperately tries to dig a hole into the
ground to crawl into and blonde lady
finally spots him she decides to be nice
and give him a helping hand and properly
digs d a proper hole for him to sleep in
saying that now that she saved his life
this makes them even but oh lo and
behold it's raining outside so the two
decide to do a typical anime thing and
wait out a passing storm while D rests
she discusses her non-important
character backstory about how vampires
killed her family and blah blah blind
How She Wants Revenge she tells Dee that
this is a lonely job then no one will
show up to her funeral when her time
comes so she makes a pact with the
non-caring D that if either one of them
dies the other one will show up to their
funeral with flowers the next day blonde
lady heads back to join up with her
group while Dee suits up and heads back
out to find Charlotte meanwhile blonde
ladies group continues to track down the
Noble's location but they soon realize
exactly where my air and Charlotte are
headed to the one place that nobody will
be able to catch them the castle of
Chaffey an ancient castle home to the
vampire lord carmilla known as the
bloody Countess her Greed for blood was
so strong that even the vampire King of
the time killed her because of her
crimes the bounty hunters have one last
shot to stop my air before he crosses
this long bridge into safety they notify
blonde hair girl on the comps that the
team is about to intercept the character
they blow up part of the bridge and stop
the carriage dead in its tracks with
only one bodyguard and the sun still
shining they think they have the noble
vampire lord cornered but that was their
biggest mistake redhead guy goes to
rescue Charlotte as werewolf stud uses
his powers to locate the rest of the
bombs hidden under the bridge in the
process of escaping he gets shot by
headband guy and he falls off the bridge
then Lord mayor steps out into the sun
burning alive in front of everyone and
he demands that the humans give back his
Charlotte and they make fun of him and
prepare to slaughter him and gut him
like a pig but that's when out of
nowhere Charlotte runs to the vampire
lord and hugs him stating that she'd
rather die than be without him but
that's when werewolf's stud shows up
again and Strikes down red-haired guy
killing him instantly panicking headbang
guy tries to donate the bombs which he
thinks are still under the bridge and
jumps down into the water just as
everything around him blows up barely
surviving the event himself lucky lucky
all the while his blonde-haired girl
helplessly watches everything unfold in
the distance and she races over to help
her probably dead crew okay this is
crazy because these guys could not have
done this Rescue Mission any more poorly
and it's clear that they rushed the plan
without thinking about it which is
obvious because they did have a lot of
time but they had more options that they
could have gone with guys let me explain
one trying to manage rescuing Charlotte
while watching out for a vampire and
werewolf means that they're outnumbered
and overpowered to begin with and well
yes it does look like this is their best
chance to attack before or they cross
the bridge they should have resisted
acting impulsively and have taken their
chance with trying to intercept the
carriage at a little bit later Point
allowing blonde hair girl to meet up
back with them that at the very least
would have allowed one more person to
watch the werewolf one person to watch
The Vampire and one person to focus on
rescuing Charlotte these people are
Human After All so watching a werewolf
falling off the bridge and thinking it's
dead is probably not a good plan to
survive headband guys a seasoned Bounty
Hunter he knows these creatures he
underestimated his opponent and paid the
price for it or well I should say
redhead guy did sorry redhead guy he
should have assumed that due to the
werewolves physiology him being stronger
than a human means that him falling from
a height that a human could survive
means that it's very likely that
werewolf guy was not dead Charlotte and
a now Kettle chipped baked Maya
continued to make their way to the
ancient castle werewolf studs senses
that D is nearby and stays behind to
fight him basically sacrificing his life
for no reason really whatsoever because
D easily takes him out and moves on to
go save Charlotte later that night Maya
and Charlotte reached the castle and are
greeted by the most terrifying dying
spirit in the world the legendary
Countess carmilla she tells them that
she's willing to help them out and
reveals to them an ancient rocket ship
used by vampires thousands of years ago
during the good old days the vampires
would use them to get from one Castle to
another she tells them that this vampy
spaceship will take them to an abandoned
city where they'll be safe and totally
not spooky foreshadowing carmilla tells
them that she made rooms for them to get
ready for their long Voyage they head to
a room where Charlotte tries to convince
Maier to bite her and turn her into a
vampire already because she's ready for
eternity he wants to but he resists
telling her that it's a curse that bears
a heavy weight and the two agree to talk
about it a little more later sensing
something is wrong he tells her to stay
in the room while he goes to handle some
unfinished business he follows his
senses right to D but that's when D
reveals Charlotte right next to him
stating that she's choosing to leave my
air stunned my air can do nothing but
stand there slicing Maya right in half
but all of a sudden D disappears
revealing that it's all an illusion
meanwhile back in Charlotte's Room she
too begins seeing strange visions and
the reality enters the castle knowing
that Charlotte is nearby he follows the
clues and walks right into a mental trap
hallucinating about his mother and his
terrifying past just outside blonde
girls crew finally arrives and finally
do the riot Thing by ghosty and tell him
to sit this one out so blonde lady and
headband guy split up to go find
Charlotte no no no
want to head in
Earth to split up after everything
they've been through and by now they
found out that their Target Charlotte
does not want to be saved and is
unwilling to cooperate with them because
killing a bounty and rescuing one and
bringing it back home alive are two very
different jobs entirely and this is
point they need to consider that aside
from her resistance they're up against a
ruthless and cruel vampire Noble and out
of her five thousand years alive she
caused a lot of pain and misery to the
human population if I was them I'd
swallow my ego and use all the help I
could get and would go and find their
only Ally in this Castle full of evil
spirits and vampires d himself because
he will be their best bet in keeping the
humans alive long enough to find
Charlotte possibly even waiting until D
kills my air and stops Charlotte from
being a threat this will allow them to
open up three possibilities one they can
swipe Charlotte and get the hell out of
Dodge while D handles my air and
carmilla wait until D kills both
vampires and then try to kill him too
that's a less likely option to succeed
but if they do put off they would get
100 of the bounty for themselves or
option 3 wait until D kills both
vampires help him out as much as we can
and agree to split the Bounty 50 50 like
gentlemen blonde lady and headband guy
began to have spooky visions of their
own and headband guy sees visions of his
dead comrades and he too finally kicks
the bucket while blonde hair girl sees
her past worthless self Dee bumps into
the blonde girl and saves her from the
illusion saying that this is the work of
the spirit of the castle the evil
Countess carmilla headband guy burst
into the Roman takes blonde hair grow
hostage and the two realize that it's an
evil spirit and that headband guy has
been bitten out of nowhere ghosty
psychic thing comes in to save the day
using up the last of his powers and
sacrificing his life to save theirs man
I'm upset he died I like that guy D then
racist to find Charlotte not realizing
that it's already too late Charlotte
gets drained of Blood by the Countess
herself setting off a host of terrifying
events Dee then runs into even more
trouble he realizes that carmilla's
corpse is coming back to life the blood
flowing from Charlotte's half dead body
begins pouring into the coffin
carmilla's Spirit then reveals to D her
desire for the vampires to run the world
once again using Charlotte's blood to
reawaken herself even further and allow
her to wreak havoc on the world once
again she tries to break Dee's will into
making him a full-on vampire monster but
he manages to break the spell and slow
her down shocking her to the Bone and
revealing a terrifying clue of Dee's
past Maya finally shows up regenerated
and good as new and steals Charlotte
away from carmilla's grasp allowing Dee
to finally kill carmilla once and for
all using his wrinkle face of a left
hand to suck her spirit into the void
late to the party as usual blonde-haired
lady finally arrives into the room and
tries to finish Meyer off but she's such
a romantic she chokes at the last minute
feeling sad for their Broken Love Dee
however does not care and picks up the
slack and tells Meyer that he must take
back Charlotte's still useful corpse
back to her family to get his Bounty and
that he must kill my ear right here and
now fire attacks D and the two duke it
out using their wish to brutally tear
each other apart the match is dead even
until blonde hair girl finally has
enough of this manly manly bro [__] and
removes Charlotte's ring from her finger
telling the two to stop fighting and
throws the ring to D which is really
great because D almost totally killed my
air barely missing his heart he picks up
the ring and tells Meyer that the ring
will do and that he will take the ring
back to Charlotte's family allowing him
to complete his Bounty Mission and get
the money with carmilla dead the castle
begins to collapse all around them the
two love birds I mean now one love bird
then enters the old rocket ship D and
blonde hair lady escaped the castle and
watched them take off into the stars
that is scared for a second they weren't
sure if it really was going to take off
but it turned out just fine blonde hair
girl then tries to act cool and tells
Dee that she'll let him have this bounty
this time she says she'll let him have
the bounty on the condition that if he
gives her a ride to the closest town he
can have it sometime later a crowd of
people gather around the funeral of
someone very special and this little
girl sees a strange man in the distance
ignoring the advice of stranger danger
she runs up to him she asks if he's the
vampire hunter that her now dead
grandmother told her about and D nods
his head yes saying that he's here to
keep a promise to an old friend to
deliver her flowers and he heads off
into the distance to handle more badass
blade-esque missions in the future but
what did you think about the video let
us know what you like about it you
didn't like about it and also don't
forget to like And subscribe